six mois de préparation d'entraînement
pour ces quelques instants jane la reine
du carnaval tropical de paris
parade sur les champs elysées c'est une
fierté pour moi de représenter les
tropiques sur la plus belle avenue du
monde et j'espère que je les représente
et correctement
voilà
[Musique]
elles étaient nombreuses sous une météo
caniculaire à faire grimper la
température
devant le jury chargé de décerner deux
récompenses des groupes de la france
entière de guadeloupe martinique guyane
polynésie nouvelle calédonie et des
formations venues de nombreux pays
nous sommes un pays le carnaval le
carnaval de la bolivie
c'est le carnaval patrimoine de
l'humanité
je salue le courage à tous les conflits
des vilains depuis deux ans parce que ça
doit être assez nombreux
un élève est vraiment un carnaval
magnifique mais par contre il manque que
les chars c'est dommage mais il ya une
super ambiance
deux cent mille spectateurs déjà comblé
par la qualification des bleus en quarts
de finale en ont pris plein les yeux au
son du ka du cha cha et des conques de
lambi avec ce carnaval
paris première destination touristique
du monde se dote d'un nouveau joyau